[Music]
well here's a trivia fact you may not
have known since 1967.
56 years the Disney Corporation has
enjoyed near total control over about 40
square miles of Florida its own little
Vatican City and this is by Act of the
Florida legislature which empowered
Disney to function effectively as its
government Disney could even acquire
territory outside its chunk of land by
eminent domain just take it from people
now last year people began to wonder why
would Disney which is a totally
politicized company they pushes race
hate race hate and sexualized propaganda
on children why would they have all
these special benefits in the State of
Florida good question so last year
Florida's legislature passed a bill
ending this weird little Arrangement
Disney had of course they hated it
voters Governor Ron DeSantis pushed for
and then signed that bill into law
Governor DeSantis joins us tonight
Governor thanks so much for coming on so
why did you see this as an important
thing to do as the governor
well as you pointed out Tucker I mean no
company or individual in Florida
probably anywhere else in our whole
country has enjoyed their own governing
status being exempt from most of many of
the laws of the State of Florida massive
subsidies so it's not a good arrangement
to begin with but if you remember last
year they came out very strong against a
piece of legislation to protect parents
rights and to protect young children
from having sexualized curriculum and
things like elementary school and then
they had Executives talking about it was
their uh intent to jam some of this
sexualized programming in the Disney
cartoons and programming for young kids
so then we're in a situation Tucker
where they're taking those positions as
a company which are antithetical to our
values but with this Arrangement Florida
was subsidizing that type of activism
that could no longer stand and so now
today in the State of Florida for the
first time since 1967 Disney no longer
has its own government they're going to
have to abide by the same laws as
everybody else they're going to finally
pay their fair share of taxes and pay
all the debts that they've racked up
over these decades but my understanding
was in a democracy unelected corporate
Executives get to make your laws for you
no
laughs
well you know there's a lot of people in
the corporate press that think that
that's what they would rather have you
know I just won by 1.5 million votes and
then I go and do what I said I would do
and they squeal they would much rather
have Disney running the show in Central
Florida but there's a new sheriff in
town and I think that this is going to
be good for the State of Florida and
I'll tell you Tucker the people that
work there have been very very thankful
that we took this action the
firefighters for example on site we're
so glad that we're finally stepping up
going to listen to them and gonna treat
them much better
so you just wrote a book about what
you've done in Florida called the
courage to be free Florida's group print
if I can pronounce it for America's
Revival it's out tomorrow what's it
about
well people would say how'd you do it in
Florida I mean we've become the focus
point of freedom in the United States
and even around the world people look at
Florida you just had someone from Spain
saying a politician she wants Spain to
be the Florida of Europe and I think
what we do is we talk about the
different fights that we've had our
approach to leadership but at the end of
the day Tucker you talk about all the
time on your show yes we got a fight
over weaning government very important
and we have a very uh vast
administrative state that we battle with
Biden but you also have Corporate
America going woke big Tech censoring so
these are fights all across the scene
and when you stand up for what's right
they come after you it isn't easy so you
got to have the courage of your
convictions to stand strong but I think
what we've shown in Florida if you do
that and people see you're willing to
fight for them they'll walk over broken
glass Barefoot to vote for you and I'm
proof positive that four years ago I won
by 32 000 votes last November I won by
1.5 million votes yeah well movement is
the ultimate election people are moving
there so that kind of tells you I would
say a lot Governor I understand thank
you very much subscribe to the Fox News
YouTube channel to catch our nightly
opens stories that are changing the
world and changing your life from Tucker
Carlson tonight